und das mega feier im berliner grunewald
das ist nicht kleiner als vor 24 stunden
das ist ihr noch größer geworden in den
vergangenen stunden ein geruch von
lagerfeuer liegt mittlerweile über der
stadt und immer mehr fragen wichtigste
gerade wann kann das endlich gelöscht
werden man hört das endlich auf das dort
auf diesem gelände weiter munition
gelagert feuerwerk wie sie hier in den
bildern sehen können explodiert auch in
den vergangenen stunden nämlich immer
wieder schwere detonationen dort im
berliner südwesten wer dort wohnt der
hat auch in der nacht nicht gut schlafen
können in diesem waldgebiet das
eigentlich so ein schönes und beliebtes
erholungsgebiet ist für alle berliner wo
aber gleichzeitig im riesige mengen an
bomben und an sprengstoff gelagert
werden seit jahrzehnten ein mega brand
der heute immer mehr fragen aufwirft
ein mega feier und drei große fragen
warum konnte das munitionslager
überhaupt brennen auch gut 24 stunden
nach ausbruch gibt es keinen einzigen
hinweis auf die ursache hat zunächst die
munition gebrannt oder zuerst der wald
war es ein unfall brandstiftung die
offizielle schweiz teno erstmal löschen
doch genau das geht ja gar nicht seit
mehr als 24 stunden warum lagert berlins
munition in der stadt viele tonnen
weltkriegsmunition in diesem lager im
beliebten grunewald hunderttausende
berliner sind gerade völlig überrascht
dass all das in ihrer stadt gelagert ist
ähnlich überrascht offenbar die politik
berlins bürgermeisterin gefeiert
kündigte bereits an die lagerung nach
dem feuer zu überprüfen ein schlechtes
gewissen und wie lange brennt es noch im
grunewald erst hieß es mehrere stunden
nun ist klar für diesen brand braucht es
langen atem die feuerwehrkräfte am rande
der erschöpfung doch das löschen hat
noch gar nicht beginnen können weiterhin
kommen die einsatzkräfte gar nicht ran
an den brand müssen abstand halten wegen
der explosionen einen kilometer auch die
große autobahn die abus liegt weiter
lahm der mega brand im grunewald noch
immer unfassbar
und unser bild feuerwehr porta benjamin
trump ist dort wieder an der
einsatzstelle benjamin wir sehen nicht
da im grunde seit 24 stunden ebenfalls
im einsatz sind die einsatzkräfte in
diesen 24 stunden irgendeinen schritt
wirklich vorangekommen
genau das gilt es heute morgen
herauszubekommen und diesbezüglich haben
wir uns hilfe geholt der pressesprecher
der berliner feuerwehr thomas kirstein
ich grüße sie inwiefern sind die retter
weiter gekommen als vor 24 stunden bzw
jetzt 28 stunden ja mittlerweile schon
ja also wir haben die ganze nacht hier
durchgearbeitet auch gemeinsam mit der
freiwilligen feuerwehr wir haben sehr
viele brände löschen können ist brennt
ja in dem sperrkreis um den sprengplatz
herum gab es ja gestern abend sehr viele
brände wir haben ja fast rund 50 hektar
wir konnten noch mal ein bisschen runter
reduzieren auf 42 hektar betroffen waren
die brände sind nahezu alle gelöscht es
gibt noch kleinere bodenfeuer die müssen
natürlich ganz genau beobachten aber da
sind wir sehr gut vorangekommen
was ist jetzt die weitere strategie der
einsatzkräfte ja das große problem
bleibt weiterhin der sprengplatz ansicht
dort war heute nacht niemand tätig und
es konnte auch nicht erkundet werden
deswegen besteht der sperrkreis von 1000
metern einfach auch weiter wir haben
aber sehr viel spezialtechnik hier ja an
gefordert ist auch aus niedersachsen
werde jetzt unterstützt wir wollen im
laufe des tages werden diese
spezialkräfte gemeinsam mit den
sprengmeistern der polizei und der
bundeswehr den sprengplatz erkunden und
das ist wichtig für die prognose wie es
hier heute weitergeht apropos erkunden
was hat der erkundungs roboter theodor
gestern für erkenntnisse liefern können
ja das war ja eine ziemlich brisante
situation theodor war gerade in der
erkundung auf dem sprengplatz als es zu
einer umsetzung haben die wir hier auch
in einem kilometer entfernung gespürt
haben das war sicherlich auch eine
gefährliche situation da vor ort sodass
der theodor zurückgezogen wurde und man
jetzt erst mal den heutigen tag abwartet
und guckt wie sich das dort
weiterentwickelt und da sind neue panzer
der fahrzeuge geplant und auch neue
roboter die stärker gepanzert sind um
nie sind auch gepanzert aber sie haben
die technische möglichkeit auch wasser
abgeben zu können und können löschen das
ist neu die haben wir extra angefordert
welche spekulationen gibt es jetzt
eventueller weise was diesen brand
ausgelöst haben könnte und vor allem ist
jetzt klar ob es erst das feuer gab oder
erst eine detonation eine explosion also
die diskussion ging ja den ganzen tag
über wir müssen uns dort wirklich in
geduld üben die brandursachenermittlung
ist von der polizei berlin aufgenommen
worden die sind sehr akribisch gehen die
davor auch die sprengmeister sind dort
beteiligt um dort die ursachen zu
erforschen aber da müssen wir uns alle
in geduld herr thomas kirstein vielen
vielen dank pressesprecher der feuerwehr
berlin also insofern erst einmal leichte
entwarnung hier aus dem berliner
grunewald die größeren flammen konnten
in der nacht glücklicherweise gelöscht
werden jetzt geht es darum den
springplatz unter kontrolle zu bekommen
da kommen neue gepanzerte fahrzeuge wir
haben es eben gehört auch gepanzerte
roboter die mitunter auch wasser abgeben
können um diesen ganzen inferno hier
schlussendlich herr werden zu können
danke für die informationen benjamin
also das war schon mal ein teil auf die
erste große frage wann kann das endlich
gelöscht werden teil entwarnung okay was
das feuer angeht gleichzeitig war man
auf diesem sprengplatz nach wie vor
nicht musste man sich sogar zurückziehen
wie herr kirsch seine feuerwehrsprecher
eben mitgeteilt hat also das bleibt dort
im grunewald ein riesiges problem es
gibt die beiden weiteren großen fragen
brandursache darüber habt ihr gesprochen
offenbar weiter totales schweigen und
dann benjamin die große frage wie kann
das überhaupt sein dass in der
hauptstadt das ist ja nicht außerhalb
oder vor den toren berlins irgendwo
draußen sondern das ist ein ganz
beliebtes erholungsgebiet wie kann das
sein dass in der stadt all diese
munition all diese weltkriegsbomben all
dieses feuerwerk das illegale gelagert
wird riesige frage und eine lange
diskussion in wahrheit schon man wollte
das lager längst schließen vor vielen
vielen fast 20 jahren wenn ihr mit
richtig 2004 gab es da einen antrag der
cdu der gesagt hat das kann doch nicht
wahr sein er wurde aufmerksam gemacht
auf diese gefahren hier im wald die
kommenden jahre es war ja da klimawandel
war ja auch schon im gespräch und diese
problematik wir müssen mal ganz kurz
platz machen für die polizei ihr im
hintergrund nicht dass der kameramann
einmal jetzt ja auch noch
zum opfer hier am grünewald wird genau
das ist das problem und warum hat man da
nicht reagiert dieser vorschlag dieser
antrag wurde einfach abgewiesen und auch
das gilt es jetzt in zukunft zu klären
in den nächsten stunden hoffentlich
tagen danke für deine informationen
benjamin tram für unser bild feuer
reporter dort bei diesem mega brand im
südwesten berlins auf diesem
munitionslager der polizei und wir
schauen noch mal auf die warnungen die s
da heute früh gegeben hat im südwesten
berlins wer die kath waren app auf
seinem handy hat der wurde in berlin
heute mit blick auf rauch gewarnt im
ganzen berliner südwesten das betrifft
ein gebiet in dem ja ungefähr 500
600.000 menschen leben die sind heute
aufgewacht in der nacht durch rauch
gerochen geruch von lagerfeuer der über
der stadt lag und ja eben das ist die
warnung von catan heute früh weiterhin
riesen gesprächsthema in ganz
deutschland dieses mega feier in berlin
die strategie der feuerwehr eben das
haben wir gerade gehört in den nächsten
stunden dann rauf zu können zum ersten
mal auf diesen sprengplatz auf dieses so
gefährliche gelände mit hilfe der
bundeswehr unsere reporter informieren
weiter direkt von dort und jetzt wieder
live zu unserem bild feuer reporter zu
benjamin trump dort in den berliner
grunewald also wir hören ein bisschen
gute nachricht aus der nach dass man da
ja das feuer hat eindämmen können und
gleichzeitig weiß man doch bisher weiter
nicht was sich tatsächlich da auf diesem
spreng geländer auf diesem sprengplatz
tatsächlich abgespielt hat was da alles
in die luft gegangen ist beispielsweise
das wollen wir jetzt rauskriegen klar
ist 42 hektar wald grunewald sind seit
gestern betroffen der sicherheitsradius
wurde gestern auf 1000 meter
eingerichtet der konnte jetzt nach
rücksprache mit dem sprengmeister
gelockert werden so dass die
einsatzkräfte jetzt in rücksprache mit
dem springen meist ein einzelfall auf
bis zu 500 meter an den brandherd heran
kommen können neben mir steht jetzt
thomas kirstein der pressesprecher der
berliner feuerwehr die löscharbeiten
laufen nach wie vor es besteht aber
unverändert die gefahr weiterer
explosionen wie gefährlich ist die lage
momentan da wir haben ja zwei große
schwerpunkte einmal ist es der
sprengplatz von dem weitere explosion
drohen wir können dort immer noch nicht
tätig werden also wir wollen heute dort
jetzt erstmal erkundung einführen dafür
brauchen wir gepanzerte fahrzeuge dass
der sprengmeister polizei berlin dort
sich ein lagebild verschaffen kann
dieses lagebild ist wichtig zur
einordnung des sperrkreises der
sperrkreis für die bevölkerung sind
weiterhin 1000 meter wir begeben uns als
einsatzkräfte die gefahr bis auf 500
meter sie haben es angesprochen haben
damit wir diesen waldbrand weiterhin
bekämpfen und auch klein halten dass
sich der wald hier nicht weiter der
waidmann sich nicht weiter ausbreitet
wie es sind jetzt die weitere strategie
der einsatzkräfte da wir wären jetzt mit
massiven löschmaßnahmen im waldgebiet
weiterhin tätig sein also in den
sperrkreis auch das machen wir von den
wegen dort wo wir an kleinere
brandnester die es immer noch gibt nicht
rankommen dort wären entweder schneisen
durch panzer der bundeswehr geschlagen
oder durch einen gepanzerten lösch
panzer oder wir werden auch mit robotern
die löschen können dort vorgehen wir
haben gestern gelernt dass schwere
bomben in speziellen behältern
aufbewahrt werden die auch gekühlt
werden welche gefahr besteht nach wie
vor vor diesem schweren bomben nur die
diese frage kann nur der sprengmeister
beantworten ja polizei berlin die jetzt
dringend dann auch dort bilder machen
möchten oder sich halt auch vor ort an
einblick verschaffen das geschieht
gemeinsam mit der bundeswehr davon hängt
eigentlich heute alles ab der bundeswehr
roboter theodor kamen gestern zum
einsatz der wurde ins brandgebiet
geschickt um bilder zu machen musste
dann aber abdrehen aufgrund von weiteren
explosionen weiteren detonationen jetzt
heute plan b was ist da angesagt denn er
musste sich gestern bei der erkundung er
war bereits auf dem sprengplatz im
einsatz zurückziehen oder die ganze
technik und natürlich auch die
einsatzkräfte diabolisch tages an enorm
nah dran waren bei dieser situation der
polizei berlin wurden wieder
zurückgezogen und man hat jetzt
praktisch die nacht abgewartet um zu
gucken wie es die entwicklung auf dem
sprengplatz ist jetzt wichtig dort vom
sprengplatz neuer kenntnisse zu kriegen
damit wir dann hoffentlich irgendwann im
laufe des tages den sperrkreis
eingrenzen können und die abos und der
bahnverkehr wieder freigegeben kann sie
haben die einsatzkräfte angesprochen wie
wird sich um die aktuell gekümmert wie
geht es denen ja wir haben frische
einsatzkräfte hier die einsatzkräfte
nach tätig waren sind alle ausgelöste
sind am feierabend so soll es sein wir
haben jetzt frische einsatzkräfte auch
der freiwilligen feuerwehr mit einer
brandschutz bereitschaft hier ist jetzt
ordentlich ressourcen technik und
einsatzkräfte da wir sind gut
aufgestellt die problematik jetzt
aktuell wetterbedingt es ist windig
geworden das könnte die flammen jetzt
nochmal erneut anfachen welche gefahr
besteht da und inwiefern wenn wir in
richtung himmel gucken hier kommt jetzt
einer dieser gepanzerten lösch roboter
an dieses alleinstellungsmerkmal können
sie uns doch mal ganz kurz erläutern wir
sind sehr froh wir haben jetzt
unterstützung aus niedersachsen die sind
gut aufgestellt die haben
spezielle technik und die komplizierten
abstimmung mit uns wir beschreiben
praktisch in kollegen aus niedersachsen
welche probleme die wir haben und die
unterstützen uns mit ihrer technik und
das ganz besondere an diesem lösch
roboter ist er kann tatsächlich nicht
nur bilder machen wie theodor gestern
sondern er kann tatsächlich auch wasser
abgeben er kann wasser abgeben das ist
der große unterschied und deswegen haben
wir diese spezielle technik herangeführt
gefahrenabwehr macht nicht an
ländergrenzen halt wir sind da gut
vernetzt bundesweit und sind
vorsichtiger sagt jetzt hier sind und
jetzt noch einmal ganz kurz wir haben
den wind angesprochen aber auch den
blick zum himmel es ist regen angesagt
wie sehr hofft man da auch als feuerwehr
auf ein bisschen unterstützung in diesen
sekunden von oben ja ich hatte vorhin
mit einem förster gesprochen fand der
vater hat es müsste schon richtig dahl
und starkregen ihm dass es uns hier
massiv nach vorne bringt im moment
erwarten wir sowieso auf den regen dann
muss man auch erst mal gucken wie viel
und ob das überhaupt auswirkungen hat
darauf verlassen wir uns nicht aus
wetter an dieser stelle wir werden hier
heute vormittag sehr sehr viel wasser in
den wald bringen mit mehreren
tanklöschfahrzeugen mit wasserwerfern
der polizei da sind wir gut vorbereitet
daher gestern löschboot einer havel in
stellung gebracht es gibt
schlauchleitung zur krummen lanke also
wasser ist hier nicht das problem vielen
vielen dank thomas kirsten
pressesprecher der berliner feuerwehr
also es wird an allen ecken und enden
dafür gesorgt dass jetzt so viel wasser
wie möglich in den grunewald gelangt wie
wir gerade eben erfahren haben
mitbeteiligt auch dieser lösche roboter
der feuerwehr der als
alleinstellungsmerkmal dass die
besonderheit hat dass er ebenfalls auch
was er abgeben kann jetzt im hintergrund
wir sehen uns die feuerwehr rückt an es
sind diverse lösch panzer der polizei
diesen kleinen blick wollen wir euch
vielleicht noch ganz kurz geben wie hier
im hintergrund der boden ist auch nass
die werden also an allen ecken und enden
immer wieder aufgetankt die sicherheit
was das wasser angeht was die
wasserzufuhr angeht die ist
glücklicherweise gedeckt also daran wird
es nicht mangeln hat eben auch thomas
kirstein noch einmal bestätigt also das
sind die aktuellen eindrücke aus dem
berliner grunewald sobald ist hier mehr
gibt melden wir uns natürlich zur handy
amin der der roboter der feuerwehr der
fährt jetzt rein dort der fährt in
richtung dieses sprengplatz ist
vielleicht können wir noch mal ganz kurz
zeigen das ist ja schon faszinierendes
gerät dort was da im einsatz ist
vielleicht auch noch mal auf das
live-bild drauf der war ja jetzt bei
unterwegs dort in das brandgebiet
richtig oder fährt er da noch richtig es
ist jetzt aber so ja es hinein jaja wird
jetzt ein bisschen eingefahren hier weil
das prozedere ist jetzt wie folgt es
wird erst es wird erst es wird erst
einen ein gepanzertes fahrzeug geben da
sitzt der sprengmeister drin der wird
jetzt in das brandgebiet gefahren dann
kommt ein gepanzertes fahrzeug was
löschen kann und dann nach rücksprache
mit dem sprengmeister kommt dieses gerät
zum einsatz was dann noch einmal ein
bisschen dichter heran geführt werden
kann sollte es zur explosion kommen
erwischt es in diesem fall
glücklicherweise nur einen roboter davon
sind hier drei im einsatz und wie gesagt
das alleinstellungsmerkmal von diesem
roboter hier von diesem gepanzerten
lösch roboter ist dass er ebenfalls auch
wasser abgeben kann sollte er dich daran
kommen ist das natürlich eine eine
fantastische neuerungen die hier jetzt
in diesem fall für abhilfe sorgen soll
er hat mit blaulicht auch fasziniert
mich gerade patricia sehr wärme plauder
der roboter der feuerwehr dort mit
blaulicht ausgestattet aber er keine
namen oder wenn alpha wolf glaube ich
nur alpha hatten die helfer wohl von
alpha wolf schön gut und seinem
hintergrund sehen wir auch an den beiden
an den beiden antennen siehst du auch
noch die verkehrsschilder rechts noch
sieht ein bisschen aus wie star wars das
jetzt hier die eindrücke aktuell aus dem
berliner grunewald ja alles gute für
alpha wolf eine wichtige aufgabe dort
heute im südwesten berlins hat ihn bei
24 stunden mehr als 24 stunden
mittlerweile auf dieses mega feier dort
blicken und darüber berichten und wir
wollen natürlich auch schauen was kommt
noch weiterhin zum einsatz denn klar ist
auch heute an tag 2 es wird derzeit
nicht gelöscht es wird verhindert dass
sich das feuer ausbreitete aber man kann
derzeit weiterhin nicht löschen dieses
feuer entfernung im berliner grunewald
auch unsere kollegin isabel pfannkuche
ist vor ort dieser welt die bundeswehr
unterstützt wir haben eben gerade den
roboter der feuerwehr gesehen inwiefern
wird weiteres gerät angefordert weitere
spezialtechnik weitere roboter damit man
endlich auch einmal an den brandherd
rankommt
es heißt dass hier wirklich die
komplette technologie des landes
eingesetzt werden soll ganz deutschland
und dass das eben auch über die grenzen
von berlin hinweg geht und wir hatten
gestern eben jahr den theodor im einsatz
der kontrolleur leider nicht
weiterhelfen sondern nur ein bisschen
aufnahmen machen und mussten dann
abbrechen wenn wir eben gehört und dann
wurde aber gestern auch noch ein lösch
panzer eingesetzt der nämlich den
vorteil hatte dass dieser auch munition
über steht also der wird eben der ist
quasi unkaputtbar und konnte deshalb in
das gebiet reinfahren gestern abend noch
später in der nacht und heute kommen
dann eben jetzt noch diese roboter aus
niedersachsen zur einsatz jetzt kommt ja
gerade einen mutter geboren
dass er jetzt macht
der wurde anscheinend auch gerade noch
an gefordert also wir sehen es werden
wirklich schwere geschütze aufgefahren
um hier diesen brand ja die regel zu
bekommen kann unsere reporter dort in
diesem brandgebiet danke auch an bild
reporterin isabel pfannkuchen patricia
wir können das noch mal kurz anschauen
wie dieses gebiet wie dieser sprengplatz
vor diesem feuer aus denn das hiesige
diskussionen nicht nur hier in der
hauptstadt wie konnte man dort überhaupt
mitten in der stadt ja noch also im
südwesten von berlin wie konnte man dort
so viel sprengstoff so viel munition
überhaupt lagern das ist ganz beliebtes
naherholungsgebiet also dann geht man
halt einfach morgens vormittags
wochenendes immer mehr mond spazieren da
geht beim laufen joggen radfahren
inlinern und da wird eben massig
munition gelagert und das seit
jahrzehnten ja das hat vor allem auch
historische gründe man suchte nach einem
platz als berlin noch getrennt war und
das war der einzige ort wo auch ja
häuser bewohner weit genug weg waren es
gab wohl mal den versuch mit robotern
abkommen zu treffen das hat nicht
geklappt und seitdem lagert maniche
männer liegt unter anderem das 500 kilo
schwere weltkriegsbombe und auch das
gesagt munition und seitdem findet dass
dort statt wird sonst kontrolliert
gesprengt aber jetzt her interessant
interessant dass 2004 schon mal im
abgeordnetenhaus das riesenthema war da
wollte man diesen sprengplatz dicht
machen da wollte man die munition von
dort loswerden alles zu gefährlich hieß
es damals kein feuerzauber im grunewald
die es damals der antrag der aber
abgelehnt wurde bedeutete das ist ja
noch mal dieser antrag vom jahr 2004
also fast 20 jahre ist das her wo man
schon wusste mensch das ist eigentlich
nicht ja nicht nicht lange dort mitten
in der stadt die munition zu lagern und
trotzdem ist es genau dabei geblieben
heute das großfeuer eben weiterhin und
man tut sie weiter das haben wir ihnen
gerade berichtet so wahnsinnig schwer
auf dieses gebiet dann vorzudringen
vormittag am mittag etwa soll das soweit
sein dann soll es die ersten
erkenntnisse geben von der feuerwehr von
der bundeswehr was ist wirklich passiert
auf diesem gelände dieses
platz ist das großfeuer in berlin
[Musik]